Shila Buff is now a Catholic he was
received into the Catholic Church by
Bishop Baron who was on this show couple
of weeks ago and this is really great
news we'd heard while Shia was making
this movie about Padre Pio that uh he
was interested in converting to
Catholicism he said that the traditional
Latin mass is what really attracted him
that's true of so many young people and
young converts they're not attracted by
the church trying to Wed herself to the
spirit of the age which leaves when you
wed yourself to the spirit of the age
you become a widow in the next age Shia
was attracted to the mass of the ages
the enduring mass that formed the vast
majority of saints throughout history
and now he's been received into the
church and that's really great news and
the reason I mention it it's not just
because I think it's good for Shia or
because I'm a mackerel snapping papist
myself but because it's a reminder that
the worst times are often the best times
we're living through very very difficult
times for the country for our culture in
the church there's a crisis in the
church going on right now